yes I seen ghosts I grew up in a haunted
house old Steeltown toys would turn out
in the middle of night channels would
flicker I woke up in the basement once
and it was the case where the whole
family was very much in the know that
there was a ghost in our house do you
have siblings I did or mean-spirited
parents perhaps
[Music]
everything that has been unexplained is
because science hasn't figured it out
yet you know I can see in the future
that we scientifically break down what
those are I'll believe in a ghost when I
see it right in front of it I mean
you're just there I think you don't have
to I don't think they're there to be
dangerous I think ghosts are just there
they're just chilling out okay official
classified packaging okay I'm already
spooked here we go when my brother was
little my mom found him running around
the living room laughing when she asked
him what he was doing he said that nice
old lady is chasing me a week or so
later she was going through old photos
when my brother pulled out a photo of my
great-grandmother who had passed away
many years before he was born
he smiled really big and said that's her
mommy
that's the lady who's chasing me and the
kids sounds like an overactive
imagination I'm down with it I had an
invisible friend a Twinkie when I was a
kid all right
Winkies your old uncle passed away
sixteen years ago going through a family
photo album chances are that's probably
the second or third old lady he's ever
seen so like I think you're giving kids
too much credit I feel like they see a
face may forget it you taste your
great-grandmother around I know she
chases terrifying my boyfriend and I
went camping together one weekend this
was back before digital cameras were
things so we brought a few disposable
ones when we went to sleep that night in
our sleeping bags we zipped up the tent
completely and locked in the zipper
we both swear to this after the photos
were developed we picked up the pictures
and we saw there was a series of
pictures taken of both of us sleeping
from inside the tent
that's crazy we're developing the mythos
here ghosts can pick up physical objects
and activate a shutter
I don't think all those are capable that
but if the ghost is strong enough I
could just be like some weirdo in the
woods yeah I don't think this was a
ghost story I think this is some creepy
Sh
where you could have been murdered
that's just like a girl's guy that came
into the tent to take these pictures
they hadn't been able to go through that
tent Bigfoot the ghost of Bigfoot
okay the ghost the Bigfoot I was like
I'm ready to be a believe Bigfoot over
the ghost of Bigfoot one night I was
reading in my room I heard footsteps
right outside my bedroom door there was
no pause there was no knock the
footsteps continue right through my
bedroom door and into my bedroom the
floorboards were creaking next to my bed
but no one was there
hm that happened to me once I was on a
bed and the corner of the bed dipped
like someone was sitting on it and I was
like oh there's nobody there I will say
so I like grew up in a really old house
and it creaked
all the time that house was haunted but
I don't think creaks necessarily
correlate to haunting I think we need
more contact like was this an old house
was it a new house
using a Ouija board in my room with some
friends we actually found a spirit to
talk to you and learned that he was an
Alaskan Eskimo he said he died in 1916
and when I asked how he spelled out Ajax
after saying our good-byes I did a
Google search and discovered that the
Ajax is an Alaskan battleship that went
into battle in the year 1916 have you
done him a Ouija board
you were wait why do you repeat you
weren't like the ghost person I was so
excited to do we use a Ouija board it
opens up things that you wanted we're
open before I don't mess with Ouija
board it's like I don't want it into my
NoHo in camp we just feel like I'm gonna
catch this boy and everyone just like
push it to yes but then we were still
alone I believe it
I do like that it wasn't like some
victorian-era spirit because that's like
everything is oh it was a girl that died
in like 1920 something and she like died
drowning in her bathtub or something
like that
one day I woke up from a short nap to my
dog barking I noticed my stepmothers
rocking chair intensely rocking back and
forth so much so that the bag sitting on
the chair fell off my stepmom has always
told me that a rocking chair rocking by
itself means someone is going to die my
grandmother passed away the next morning
mom killed the grandpa
I believe it I think some things happen
that way you have the rocking of a chair
or you have like maybe a weird dream and
then a week later something happens that
that that okay I have never really yeah
cuz you know stuff that I don't know
like the stuff about the kids
I can talk to ghosts I've never heard
that and I I have dogs like they make my
the recliner that they jump on rock all
the time and if he was asleep the dog
could have rocked it and now that I was
barking at it I don't mess when animals
are freaking out if I'm animals freaking
out I run my fence thinks that's true my
grandmother gave me a necklace before
she passed away
a year after she gave it to me I lost it
after desperately searching for it at
Comley said I'm sorry I lost the
necklace ninny can you help me find it
almost immediately the necklace fell out
of my open jewelry sand so she's
terrible looking for things it was in
that lower focusing on here why don't
you just look in the jewelry stand in
the first place it seems like that's the
first place you'd look for a lost
necklace it fell out of her jewelry soon
how does it fall out of the jeweler's
think it's all connected for a great
ghost story right every thought all that
I was gonna say this is like your
shining moment I feel like this has all
of the like trappings of like a very
like a solid ghost story
I had a neighbor who was a lovely old
man he would always work in his garden
and I'd walk past his house daily so we
spoke often one day sell him and said
hello but got no response not wanting to
bother him I carried on later I learned
that the man had gone hiking a week ago
had a heart attack and died that just
recovered his body he had been dead for
a week but I had seen him just the day
earlier well I'll let you have the first
one do you you don't think event I think
it's a thing as possible
oh boy loves his garden I think spirits
go back home to where they are to where
it's like comfortable to that really
gotta get rid of those weeds out yeah my
petunias just aren't gonna look that
great without this yeah I guess who's
gonna do it that's true yeah maybe
somebody's tending to his garden like
trying to keep the property value up all
he's dead I don't know people don't only
go to like property value immediately
when I family like maybe he was a very
devoted liked plant plant dad and he
would be heartbroken if he knew that his
plants were gonna die after so he came
back as a ghost and he could carry them
I love it I still believe in ghosts I
think they're some of these stories are
questionable I still don't believe in
ghosts but I do think that some of these
are some really good stories but a lot
of these are more like reveals or
realizations of after the fact of like
and very specific realizations and
reveals so maybe the people that think
that these things happen are actually
like remembering things in a different
order or more likely they smoke a lot of
weed so ghosts are just kind of like
impolite and don't really respect your
space most of the time yeah sounds like
because supposedly if it's a ghost in
like that's attached to a space they
don't respect your space because it's
secondly their space and you're not
respecting their space right okay is
there a ghost with us today no
BuzzFeed isn't haunted
[Music]